so now you see my title today we're
going to talk about deep learning and
machine learning in our so by now we all
have seen this Venn diagram right you
have to have this by our very own drew
Conway the original progenitor of the
arc meet up and it's like a rule you
need to show this at a data science
Meetup
all right there's even data science
bingo and this is one of the slots that
you need to fill but there's rumblings
of a new Venn diagram this comes from
the deep learning book and what it says
is that AI is this encompassing field
and that machine learning is a subset of
that and within machine learning you
have deep learning now some people say
that deep learning is its own thing not
comparable to the rest of machine
learning other people will just say it's
one technique of machine learning we're
going to dive into both of those for a
little bit but first when you're getting
into them you need to learn about them
so we need some good books and there's
plenty of good books in both fields on a
theoretical side you have the elements
of statistical learning by hasty tip
Johnny and Friedman then you have deep
learning right to the point
by Goodfellow Ben geo and kohrville now
these are both math books they're heavy
on math heavy on theory if you want to
learn how to do the code we have applied
predictive modeling by Max or are you
max right there and deep learning with
our by JJ lair where's JJ JJ somewhere
there is now these books are just code
so if you wanted to learn the theory
first read the other two books you want
to learn code read these two books
highly recommend all four of them
they're really really good reads take it
with you when you go to the beach
excellent for that
now the two disciplines have the same
things but different words some reason
there's been a massive split and the
terminology used between machine
learning a deep learning and it could be
infuriating all right so let's see some
examples of that first up we have linear
regression because that is solves a
majority of your problems
so first up and it looks like we do not
have internet for my slide so my latex
math is gone Oh No Glade Tech's map is
there I just live in my screen wonderful
y equals a plus BX simple linear
regression we've all seen this I hope
we've all seen this if you haven't seen
it in terms of statistics this is slope
intercept form from middle school all
right we've had it a and B but those
terms have very different words
depending what field you're in machine
learning calls it an intercept deep
learning calls it a bias then the B term
what comes after that machine learning
calls it coefficients whereas deep
learning calls them weights
well that's a problem because in
statistics a bias is something
completely different in the
bias-variance tradeoff huge important
concept and weights in statistics are
how much you value each row so it's
they're completely reusing terms not
just a new term they're reusing a term
and that could be very difficult to get
your head around then we have this curve
it is generically a binary scaling curve
right we all know the math behind this
it's 1 over 1 plus e to the negative x
all right
well depending on your field it's either
either an inverse logit or a sigmoid we
needed a new word for cos inverse logit
just didn't sound cool then we have l2
penalization incredibly important shows
up in a lot of algorithms and beyond
machine learning statistics it shows up
everywhere this is essentially the sum
of the squares of the terms
very important penalty is the l 2-norm
the squared l 2-norm actually and a
machine learning that's a ridge and a
deep learning it's weight decay and then
when it comes time when you have new
data and you're trying to score your new
data well that is in mathematical terms
y hat equals F hat of X tilde in machine
learning that's prediction and in deep
learning that's inference but that word
is really problematic so you're using it
for prediction here but in statistics
inference means explanation you're
actually explaining things and the first
time I heard people talking about using
inference for prediction I'm like that's
just wrong but throughout history
there's been lots of terms for the same
thing you just got to learn when to use
which one depending on your crowd so
let's get into some our code that's
we're all here for today the examples
are going to be looking at our
supervised learning y is a function of X
that's majority what people do in
particular particularly we are going to
look at binary classification because
let's be honest 90% of the time when
someone has AI they're doing a logistic
regression so let's take a look at this
let's first look at machine learning
traditional ml and we're going to focus
on today just two algorithms glim net
and X G boost probably two of the most
important powerful algorithms in machine
learning for either one the first thing
we have to do is set up our matrices so
in when you're using LM or g LM you can
just put in your formula and the data
frame it all works nicely you can't do
that with these algorithms you need to
provide the matrices in numeric format
ahead of time fortunately the useful
package there's a function called build
X that will build a for you and build Y
you give it the formula like you would
have for a regular model give your data
frame and in this case I am saying
contrast equals false this way we don't
drop the baseline of categorical
variables and sparse equals true to have
a sparse matrix because sparse matrices
take up less space and they compute
faster I'm using the credit datasets
nice small data set tiny data that
everyone's familiar with now while I use
build X for this it is theoretically
possible to use the recipes package but
the function out I wanted wasn't ready
yet by time I wrote this but max has
promised me it's on github already Thank
You max just a little too late for me so
let's talk about the elastic net which
is a combination of l1 and l2
penalization and that's implemented in
glim net by hasty tips Ronnie and
Friedman and the really cool thing about
that package is it's actually written in
73 lines of Fortran that's it and
everyone your molecular know that for
trans of verbose language and they
somehow did that it's amazing what they
did so let's fit our first model with
one line of code we not only fit a
penalized regression we did
cross-validation over the lambda we fed
it the X we fed it the Y told us a
binomial regression and do ten folds and
one line of code we got all of that done
nice simple easy and when we're done of
that we can visualize the coefficient
path using coop F if you're used to
using the gloom net package you could
plot the model but it's static it's hard
to see so I used I graphs to build coop
ass which now has it interactively you
could zoom in you can hover and see
what's happening and as you read this
you could see that as your lambda your
penalty increases the coefficients
shrink towards zero and eventually get
to zero and that's your minimization
nice quick easy visualization let's say
you have one value of lambda and you
want to see the point estimates for your
coefficients you can use cough plot tell
it you want to use lambda dot min and it
very quickly shows you the point
estimates for each of your coefficients
much better than a table of numbers out
to like five decimal places you can very
quickly and easily see the impact of
each individual coefficient now of
course if you're using a regular linear
model you would have confidence
intervals but penalize regression
doesn't give you confidence intervals
but who cares about that anyway these
days no one seems to care about calm
intervals right is machine learning and
making a prediction that's going to last
five seconds so you don't care anymore
but maybe you should
so that is penalized regression the next
algorithm I want to talk about our
decision trees and despite their name of
decision tree they actually do both
regression and classification
they're called decision trees not
because of the outcome variable was
because of a series of decisions as you
split up the input variables and well
there's lots of ways you can do this
we're going to skip straight to X G
boost because it's just like the most
awesome thing put out there machine
learning recently before we actually fit
the model we're going to take one more
data step we're going to create a
special object an x gb d matrix which
stores the x and y variables in one
object for you to keep them together
we're doing that before our training
data and our validation data but notice
this they call the X the X matrix data
and the Y matrix label regression was
clearly an afterthought when they were
building this right otherwise they would
have called it X and Y or predictor and
response or input and output they were
clearly thinking about classification
but now that we have our data ready
let's fit the model with one line of
code sure I broke it up on multiple
lines so it would fit on the screen but
it's just one line of code you give it
that special data set you tell it you
want to use GB tree and that's cool
because if you switch it to GB linear
it's going to fit an elastic net XG
boost can fit penalized regression
models we're going to stick to the tree
you tell it's a logistic model I do 500
rounds I said early stopping I give it
validation data and I get a nice model
and what's really cool is this works on
a GPU now boosted trees are sequential
but when you're searching for the split
in each of the trees that could be in
parallel and you could do it on a GPU
and it could be incredibly fast even
faster the next G boost already is and
you can even have an experimental
concept here where you could do a
boosted random forest that's really
awesome you can fit multiple trees in
parallel and then boo
those groups of parallel trees when
you've done of this you get a variable
importance plot and you can very quickly
see which variables were important in
the fitting not the impact of the
variables but the importance of them and
if you want to try to visualize all 500
trees in one you can it does its best to
compress 500 trees into one tree and
show you representative splits is this
understandable in the slightest no but
it's a good first effort and we will
applaud them for that but in case you
want it to be even simpler we can use
the carrot package this provides a
uniform interface in our for all the
machine learning needs it's incredibly
simple and it's been around for over a
decade this is the original auto ml they
couldn't ask for anything better than
this
so there's two models I just fit each
one can be done in a single line of code
if you have a formula a data frame and
the only difference between these two
snippets of code are the method one is
glim net one is xgb tree so thank you
max for making it so easy so that's
machine learning very quickly next we
have deep learning and everyone's
excited about deep learning now right
it's all the rage but I think a better
name for it is extreme nonlinear
modeling because that's where you're
getting the power from it's the
nonlinearities it's the activation
functions that give you the
nonlinearities and that's where the real
strength is that's yxg boost works so
well it's capturing nonlinear
relationships the two primary ways of
doing this in our rmx net and Karis MX
net is championed by Amazon and Karason
tensorflow by Google there's a slight
issue you can't have both of them loaded
in the same our session but JJ lares
promised to fix for me he I'm taking
that as a promise now we can do other
neural networks in our end net by Brian
Ripley has been around for decades the
good only do single layer you can also
do CMT
okay deep net RNN dar CH r CP PDL
there's no shortage of deep learning at
our despite what people say there's many
packages to do it in our
so first let's rebuild our matrices same
as before but we can't use sparse
matrices because neither MX net nor
Karis slash tensorflow
can handle sparse matrices that's okay
though because we're going to have large
data we can use iterators and generators
to load them into memory a little bit at
a time because they use stochastic
gradient descent they don't need all the
data so first let's look at an MX net
this was for awhile the primary way to
do it at our it's portable to Windows
Linux Android raspberry pi and a CPU or
GPU this is an MX net model a simple MX
net model we first do a layer dropout to
prevent overfitting we have a fully
connected layer which is a dense layer
all the inputs are connected to all the
temporary in-between nodes we use a rel
u activation function we do drop out
then we do another fully connected layer
of another round a drop out and another
Lu until we get to our last layer which
is just one because it's binary and it's
1 or 0 and we have an output a logistic
regression output and that's the sigmoid
output or the inverse load yet we're not
ready yet
we need helper functions we first need
to write our own custom log loss
function because it's not one built-in
so we use log loss because that's better
than binary loss if you want to keep
track of your results you need to create
a logger to keep track of your metrics
as you go so now that we build that we
can go fit the model so first you need
to feed it your x and y matrices you
tell the optimizer you want
I chose Adam for adaptive momentum you
give it your valuation data to see how
you're going I'm doing this on a CPU I'm
choosing to use log gloss as my metric
I'm doing 50 passes through the data I
set my learning rate I set my batch size
I tell it how the data set up I have a
callback to check my metrics and then
I'd say verbose and I could run this a
lot of options you need to set just
right so then we get the outcome of this
we can plot it you
digraphs and we can see how we're doing
overtime
clearly this datasets not appropriate
for deep learning it's a very messy
thing our loss functions all over the
place but you get the idea you can see
how you're doing and our data set
definitely needs to train for much
longer if we want to keep doing this
well let's see the new kid in town let's
check out Karis this is a port of Karis
thanks to JJ lair and francois chalet
and you by default it uses tensorflow as
a back-end it's primarily meant for
Linux but it does work on Mac and on
Windows and you can use a GPU mostly on
Linux I've tried a few ways to hack it
into Windows but it's mostly on Linux
so let's design our network this is a
similar network to before but using
Kerris notation and our first layer
which is a lake called a layer dense now
we tell it we want 512 nodes and instead
of specifying the activation layer
separately we specify it right in the
layer dense function and for your first
layer you need to tell the input shape
which if you take your dimensions you
forget the one that's about the number
of samples it's the number of features
and if you have multi-dimensional
tensors you have to give a few of these
but for our data set we just tell the
number of columns we then do batch
normalization to help with the fit we do
drop out then we do another dense layer
another passional ization
another drop out and we do a sigmoid
output but after we set up the network
we then have to compile it we set the
optimizer to be Adam again and this time
our loss function is binary
cross-entropy which is the same thing as
log loss but we needed a new word we use
accuracy as our metric and notice here
you're not saving this back to an object
it's not like traditional are you're
modifying the variable in place so net
Kerris has now been modified by calling
compile on it and it is a different
object now it's been changed it's been
mutated so it's very important to note
it's a little different than standard R
so now that we've compiled it we can go
ahead and train our model we tell it the
number of epochs the batch size we want
our validation data again
and then we say callbacks because you
can't just say early stopping you need a
callback that at the end of each epoch
says hey should I stop you need to call
back for showing us your metrics you
need to call back for changing your
learning rate you need to call back for
tensor board so after you've gone and
trained the model this time only on 10
epochs you can once again see how you're
doing over time and compare your
training and validation set clearly our
model needs a lot of work we need to
train it more Andy maybe use different
data set but that's the goal behind this
not every data set is from suited for
deep learning so wrapping up
let's what's the big picture of this
well you could use centuries-old terms
or you could use brand-new terms for
machine learning there are many many
many packages carrot has 238 algorithms
you could choose from deep learning
there's about seven but deep learn has
only been around for a few years so it
is a very very good start
machine learning for the most part you
could do in a one line of code but in
deep learning it takes many many lines
of code so you have to know what you're
doing it's more verbose machine learning
we have carrot thank goodness and deep
learning there is carrot but it could
only do simple networks it can't really
do extreme deep networks you can do
simple networks machine learning you
might get some explanation out of your
models if you're doing a linear model
and maybe a single tree decision tree
deep learning it's just for predictions
and machine learning we already give you
strong predictions and deep learning
Mike give you better predictions when it
does better it does really better it
really does better now where they're
both the same they both have some really
really great bulks out there like I
showed earlier I highly recommend all of
those and both fields still have a ton
of excitement about it and that everyone
is very deeply excited about all of
these so thank you very much
you
you